days after one of uganda's worst
massacres at a school in the west
desperate parents look for their missing
children
42 bodies have been recovered at this
police station families are submitting
DNA samples hoping it will help identify
their children
mine is not yet found
so I'm still waiting I'm there in this
space weather
her in the way
last week suspected Fighters attacked
this high school they set a dormitory
full of boys alight then attacked a
dormitory full of girls hacking victims
to death with machetes and knives six of
the students were abducted
the Ugandan government says there were
fighters from an isil-affiliated group
based across the border in eastern
Democratic Republic of Congo while some
of the bodies of those killed have been
identified the condition of the
remaining bodies means they can only be
identified through DNA those ones who
bands
we are using scientific methods of using
the DNA
and in that we have got samples from
both the bodies and we are getting
samples from the relatives
of the missing students
there are many others like this man
Simon cooler looking for their children
as police question at least 20 suspects
searching for answers
Al Jazeera